They’d spent hours making the costume.
The two young boys - let’s call them Johnny
and Max - had always been on the creative
side.
Sometimes they got teased for it at school,
but they didn’t care.
As long as they had each other, they could
handle anything - they were best friends.
Maybe one day, they’d build great things
together out of concrete and steel, but for
now, they worked with cardboard.
Prior projects had included building a rocket
out of cardboard in Johnny’s back yard,
like the kind that put a man on the moon.
They also made a box fort like no other - more
a box castle, really.
The kind that would stand for a hundred years
- as long as it didn’t rain, of course.
But all of that felt like nothing compared
to The Tunnel Monster.
To those two young friends, it was a thing
of beauty.
A fully articulated cardboard monster costume,
meticulously cobbled together from boxes,
masking tape, cardboard tubes for arms and
legs, and a little twine to bring it all together.
Frankenstein?
Dracula?
Freddy Kreuger?
Those silver-screen phonies were nothing compared
to The Tunnel Monster.
They even cut out eye holes in the head, and
drew the scariest, snarling mouth they could
right below.
The making was over, and now, they were ready
to play.
Johnny and Max took the costume down to one
of their favorite places in town: The abandoned
Brecher Construction Site.
To many, it would seem like a strange and
dangerous place for two children to play,
but for Johnny and Max, it was perfect.
After all, they were at the age where they
had more imagination than sense.
Max would be the one wearing the costume.
Johnny helped him put it on, piece by piece,
using extra masking tape and twine where necessary
to fasten all the pieces together.
Little by little, Max became the Tunnel Monster,
the transformation was complete and it was
finally time for the games to begin.
Johnny ran, wielding a stick as a defensive
weapon while Max gave chase.
He could feel his own hot breath within the
cardboard mask.
It was oddly exhilarating.
He gave a monstrous roar and charged after
his friend, chasing him into the child-sized
pipes of an unfinished water drainage system.
It was more fun than anything they could have
imagined.
Max really got into his role.
He lunged forwards, grabbing Johnny with his
cardboard gauntlets and tried to drag him
back into the tunnel all the while giving
low, guttural growls.
Johnny laughed, and swatted at Max with his
stick like a knight wielding a sword.
They ran and crawled through the tunnels,
the best of friends having the best of times,
making the kinds of memories that would last
forever.
And in that sense, they were right.
Something they made that day would echo on
forever, but it wouldn’t be something they
would look back upon fondly.
If they weren’t so busy running through
the tunnels, Max and Johnny might have noticed
that something was amiss.
They might have seen that, even though it
was only 3:00 PM on a Summer’s day, the
sky was beginning to darken.
It may not have saved them, but it might have
given them time to prepare for what was coming.
Max was still chasing Johnny down a pipe,
still fully in character as the Tunnel Monster,
his arms extended to grab his fleeing friend
when Johnny tripped.
Max stopped to help him up but something was
wrong.
When Max helped Johnny stand up, Johnny instinctually
pushed him away, as though it wasn’t actually
his friend anymore.
Max stumbled backwards in shock and horror.
He could feel something changing beneath the
cardboard.
He was suddenly in pain, this terrible pain.
Like he was being pulled apart and put back
together.
He started to scream.
It was a horrible sound, like nails on a chalkboard.
Johnny had to hold his ears as the screaming
got louder and louder, but Max couldn’t
stop.
He was hurting too much to stop.
Johnny was crying.
He didn’t know what was happening, only
that his friend was in terrible pain and there
was seemingly nothing he could do to stop
it.
Even Max didn’t know much more than that,
but he thought it must have something to do
with the suit.
It felt like it was full of fire ants, crawling
and biting.
It felt like his body was full of fire ants.
He needed to take the suit off before it got
any worse.
But he couldn’t, the suit wouldn’t come
off.
He reached for the cardboard mask and tried
to tug it off his head, but it wouldn’t
budge.
It felt like he was tugging at the skin of
his own face.
He could suddenly feel everything that brushed
against the cardboard, like it was connected
to his nerve endings.
The fear and the panic got worse and he kept
screaming.
It was a deafening, ear-splitting scream.
He didn’t know it, but anything electrical
within a 200 meter radius was dying.
TVs shut off.
Radios fizzled out.
Cars stopped running.
Nobody who didn’t work for the SCP Foundation
would ever know why.
It wasn’t even 3:30 PM, but the sky above
looked black as midnight.
Max was afraid but all he could do was cling
to the familiar - he lunged forwards and grabbed
Johnny, pulling him into his trembling embrace.
Is he still Max now?
No, he doesn’t think so anymore.
He’s something else entirely.
As he held his friend, Max tried to dig his
fingers into the mask and tear it off.
They pierced through the cardboard, tearing
holes into it.
It was agonizing, but the mask stayed put.
There was no escape.
He closed his eyes, just for a moment.
Maybe it was a bad dream.
Maybe he could make it disappear.
But it didn’t disappear - only he did.
Max was no more.
There was only the Tunnel Monster.
When Johnny woke up, he was disoriented and
afraid.
He was in complete darkness but he could feel
the old metal of a rusty railroad track beneath
his feet.
He didn’t remember how he got there, and
he didn’t remember Max either.
Not his face or even his name.
But that’s alright - Max didn’t remember
him either.
When the terrified Johnny eventually found
his way out of the old railway tunnel he’d
somehow found himself in, he was rescued by
emergency services and treated for dehydration.
Because of the incredibly strange circumstances
of his disappearance and reappearance over
4,000 kilometers away, it was only natural
for the SCP Foundation to check in.
But, seeing as Johnny had no memory of where
he was prior to his mysterious teleportation,
all they ever did was investigate the tunnel
he’d appeared in.
Of course, they didn’t find a thing.
The case was closed shortly afterwards, written
off as a kind of one-off spatial anomaly.
Johnny was given amnestic treatment, and reintegrated
back into his normal life.
He would never remember his encounter with
the Tunnel Monster.
But many would, for decades and decades to
come.
There would be stories and scattered witness
accounts from all kinds of people.
Maintenance workers doing electrical repairs
on subway tunnels, sewer workers cleaning
out blockages in pipes, road workers fixing
the asphalt in underpasses.
The challenge with being an SCP Foundation
field agent is often separating the genuine
leads from the urban legends and spooky stories,
but the details here were all too similar
and specific.
After all, it would be such a strange thing
to make up - a moldy old pile of cardboard
boxes, getting up and running towards you?
But stranger still, these incidents and encounters
were occurring all over the United States,
with the only commonalities being that all
of them happened in tunnels or tunnel-like
structures.
The Foundation didn’t know if they were
dealing with one entity, or many.
Another peculiar factor they observed was
that sometimes, people who had encounters
with the Tunnel Monster then themselves appear
in tunnels extremely far away from the ones
in which they first encountered it.
As far as the Foundation was aware, besides
transporting them vast distances, it never
actually harmed any of its victims.
But according to one Boston sewer worker,
Gus Zagarella, when the Tunnel Monster laid
its cardboard hand on him, he felt the most
profound sense of paranoia and dread.
He described it as feeling like a thousand
eyes in the dark, watching you die.
Then, he blinked, and he woke up in an Arizona
viaduct, roughly six hours later.
Everyone who reported a similar experience
with the Tunnel Monster was detained, debriefed,
and given amnestics by the Foundation.
Eventually, they gathered enough data on prior
encounters to accurately predict the next
tunnel that the Tunnel Monster would manifest
inside.
A new Mobile Task Force was formed to secure
the creature: MTF Nu-4, also known as the
"Box Cutters.”
What they didn’t expect, when they finally
engaged the beast, was that it was no larger
than a human child.
It wasn’t some huge, tunnel-dwelling nightmare;
even after all these decades, the Tunnel Monster
was little more than a frightened, lonely
little boy.
He growled, attempting and failing to come
off as intimidating to these hardcore MTF
members, and referred to himself as the Tunnel
Monster.
When they didn’t react with fear and surprise
like all the others, he became subdued.
They were able to peacefully apprehend him,
and take him back to Site-54 for testing and
containment.
Preliminary X-Rays found that the cardboard
costume hadn’t just fused with the boy,
it had completely transformed him.
On the inside, he was filled with crude, cardboard
copies of all the major internal organs, with
his blood vessels and nerve endings made out
of colored pieces of string.
They couldn’t find any information on who
the boy once was, if he had ever been a boy
at all, and he was given the designation SCP-3663.
In order to find out more, one of the leading
researchers on the SCP-3663 case, Researcher
Doyle, decided to conduct an interview with
the Tunnel Monster.
It has been the only interview with the creature
to date, due to the emotional distress it
caused the creature.
When asked about its identity, it replied
with only, “The tunnel monster.”
When asked why it attacked and teleported
people to different locations, the creature
replied, “The tunnel monster captures people.
That's me, I'm the tunnel monster.
I…
I capture people and take them into the tunnels
where I live.
In the tunnels.
The pipes.
I'm the tunnel monster.”
As the interview progressed, the Tunnel Monster
became increasingly upset, until it began
weeping through its cardboard face, finally
culminating with it crying out between sobs,
“Please.
I don't want to play anymore.”
SCP-3663 only feels comfortable in tunnels,
and it will teleport away in distress if confined
anywhere else.
As such, its containment chamber is technically
the maintenance tunnels underneath Site-54,
where it seems to have made a home for itself.
Occasionally, if it experiences fear, damage,
or stress, it may demanifest and appear in
tunnels elsewhere.
At that point, the Box Cutters are deployed
to collect 3663 once again and bring him back
to Site-54.
So far, there has only been one major containment
breach with SCP-3663, but it was a little
more deadly than you might expect for a boy-sized
creature made of cardboard.
The Tunnel Monster escaped from the Site-54
tunnels, and began wailing in pain.
It went positively berserk, attacking surrounding
staff and trashing parts of the facility.
Anyone who heard the wails of the Tunnel Monster
reported becoming extremely psychologically
disturbed by them.
During this four hour rampage, the monster
also tried multiple times to destroy itself
with various implements, but was unsuccessful.
After SCP-3663 was recontined, two deceased
members of personnel were recovered from the
scene.
Autopsies showed the cause of death was a
buildup of paper residue and wood pulp in
all of their major blood vessels, as well
as sinuses, ear tubes, and the majority of
the digestive and respiratory systems.
A number of other staff members were found
to have been affected to a lesser degree,
but are expected to make full recoveries.
What triggered this explosive and deadly outburst?
Not even the Tunnel Monster itself knew the
answer to that question.
But we do.
At exactly the same time, a 79 year old man
passed away from natural causes after what
seemed like a thoroughly unremarkable life.
That man’s name was Johnny.
Now check out “SCP-1762 - Where The Dragons
Went” and “SCP-3999 - I Am At The Center
of Everything That Happens To Me” for more
tragic and terrifying anomalies from SCP Explained.